all right thank you for joining us today
today we are going to hear from dr
sergio rutella on the immune correlates
of tp53 mutational status and acute
myeloid leukemia
so dr rotella joins us from the
nottingham trent university in the uk
he's a licensed hematologist and
professor of cancer immunotherapy there
over the last 25 years professor rutella
has been engaged in clinical and
translational research focusing on
immunotherapy approaches to improve
the outcome of hematological
malignancies with an emphasis on
antibody-based therapeutics and
hematopoietic stem cell transplantation
his research programs focus on
visualizing the state of cancer immune
interactions in individual patients and
on biomarker discovery
with the aim to design rational
immunotherapy approaches
and to guide treatment choices so thank
you so much for joining us we look
forward to your presentation dr rutela
thank you very much for the kind
introduction and thank you for the
invitation for the opportunity to
present today
so this is my disclosure slide i have
been receiving
research support from microgenics and
nanostring technologies and this is
relevant to my talk today
so my laboratory is currently working on
the high dimensional analysis of the aml
immunological
tumor microenvironment using targeted
immune gene expression profiling
on the encounter platform but also
geomics
digital spatial profiling dsp to try and
elucidate
the topography of the immune infiltrate
and how this correlates with
immunotherapy responses
we also have an interest in identifying
the oncogenic pathways
that drive immune infiltration in aml
and
as well as in solid tumors including
tp53 mutations which
will be the main focus of my
presentation today
so just to provide you with a bit of
background
about aml so chemotherapy remains the
standard of care for most patients with
aml
despite recent approvals of novel drugs
primary refractory or chemotherapy
resistant disease
so-called primary induction failure pith
as defined by not
achieving complete remission occurs in
approximately 20 percent
of the patient population the five-year
overall survival from first relapse for
patients with aml
is only 10 so the investigation of new
molecularly targeted and
immunomodulating agents
remains a high priority for those in
this space
and there's also an urgent need for
predictive biomarkers
to help identify patients who are more
likely to respond to cancer
immunotherapy
in this respect the tumor inflammation
signature or this
has been shown to predict response to
platitudes of immunotherapy in aml and
these
results have been recently published by
my group in science translational
medicine
so this slide summarizes a written work
that used immune gene expression
profiling of
290 bone marrow samples from patients
with
chemotherapy naive aml this analysis
identified three distinct gene
expression profiles
namely an interferon dominant profile
including highest
expression of interferon gamma pdl1 pdo2
inflammatory chemokines and interferon
downstream signaling molecules
and adaptive profile including high
expression of t
cell b cell and natural killer cell
markers
and the myeloid profile including high
abundance of polymorphonuclear cells
macrophages and other cells of the
myeloid lineage
scores were then used in aggregate to
stratify
patients into an immune infiltrated and
immune depleted subgroup as
shown in panel a patient in the immune
infiltrated subgroup
had higher levels of interference
stimulated genes
t cell and cytotoxicity markers
molecules implicated in antigen
processing and presentation
and also actionable negative immune
checkpoints such as
pdl1 btla ctla4 and tin3
as shown in panel b
the interferon related rna profiles
improves our ability to predict
chemotherapy resistance
compared with the eln cytogenetic risk
classifier alone
as shown by the arrow values in panel c
we've recently used geomics digital
spatial profiling to
identify protein co-localization
patterns
with prognostic relevance in t cell
infiltrated aml
so this highly multiplexed technology
allowed us to quantify 31
immuno-oncology related proteins in 10
bone marrow
fspes from patients with newly diagnosed
aml
so as shown in panel a we analyzed 240
geometric regions of interest
with varying degrees of t cell
infiltration
and we identify the prognostic 7-protein
signature
which is referred to as signature 3
in panel b and includes
cytotoxicity molecules such as granzyme
b fox p3
pdl1 as well as stat 3 and bcl2
so when evaluated in physical our
protein signature was deregulated at the
rna level
in approximately 25 percent of tcga
aml patients who mostly clustered in the
immune infiltrated subgroup
and as shown in the mutation enrichment
plot in panel b
in this figure the regulation of
signature 3 genes
significantly correlated with tp53
mutational stages
and approximately 55 of the patients
with
tp53 abnormalities in tcga aml
had a missense mutation as shown in
panel c
aml patients with the regulated levels
of signature 3
genes tended to have adverse cytogenetic
risk
as summarized in panel a and also had
significantly shorter relapse free
survival and overall survival
as suggested by the kevlar major kerbs
in panel b
so to summarize this first part of my
talk
we identified an experimentally derived
protein signature which
is associated with immune infiltrated
aml with
tb53 mutations and ultimately correlates
with poor clinical outcomes
so is db53 a new genetic driver of
immune infiltration in aml
so let me provide you some background
about tb63 mutations in this disease
so mutations of tp53 occur in eight to
ten percent of the
novel aml cases and are associated with
chemotherapy resistance with high risk
of relapse and with
very poor prognosis even after
hematopoietic stem cell transplantation
the functional consequences of b53
mutation inactivation on host
immunological responses have been
largely
overlooked in aml the p53 mutants
studied thus far in aml do not show any
evidence of gain of function mechanisms
so we ask the question whether p53
abnormalities
correlate with the composition and
functional orientation
of the tumor immunological
microenvironment in aml
to do so we initially downloaded rna
sequencing data from tcga a collection
of 147 cases of non-promyelocytic
aml including 14 patients with mutations
of tpp53
we then computed immune cell type
specific
and biological activity gene signatures
as
predefined linear combinations of
relevant gene cells
which were then correlated with
prognostic molecular lesions including
tp53 mutational status and pm1
mutational status
3 itd and clonal hematopoiesis of
undetermined
potential chip defining mutations in
ax sl1 tet2 and dnmt3a
and with clinical outcomes
we also profiled primary bone marrow
samples from
42 treatment naive patients with tp53
mutated aml
and 22 treatment naive patients with
tb53 wild-type aml using the
pan cancer io 360 panel from nanostream
technologies
and finally we analyze primary bone
marrow samples from
45 patients with relapsed refractory aml
who were treated with lotitude map
15 patients in this cohort had either
tp53 mutations or 17p abnormalities
with genomic loss of tp53
so panel a in this slide shows
unsupervised hierarchical clustering of
44 immune gene signatures in 118
tcga cases with non-chromatocytic aml
and available information on prognostic
molecular lesions
including 14 individuals with tp53
mutations
two patient subgroups were clearly
identified here
namely patients with high and low levels
of immune infiltration
and compared with tcga cases with
favorable risk
and intermediate risk molecular features
all
patients with tp53 mutations showed
high levels of immune infiltration and
had
higher tumor inflammation signature
scores inflammatory chemokine scores
interferon gamma signaling scores and
lymphoid scores as
summarized in panel b and
in particular the expression of immune
checkpoints
pdl1 and digit and molecules associated
with an immune suppressed tumor
microenvironment such as the t-reg
transcription factor fox p3 was
significantly higher in tp53 mutated
patients as shown in penalty
and in line with previous findings the
kaplan-major
curves in palodi highlight that
overall survival was significantly
shorter
4.5 months in patients with tp-53
mutated aml compared with 18.5
months in patients harboring other risk
defining
molecular lesions
so we then profiled pre-treatment bone
marrow samples as i just mentioned from
42 patients with
tp53 mutated aml as shown in the pie
chart in panel a
most patients in this cohort have misens
mutations of tp53
which are often associated with tp53
loss of function
principle component analysis in panel b
highlights that
immune cell type specific scores and
biological activities course
distinguished very clearly patients with
tp53 mutated aml
from individuals with tp53 wild type aml
as shown by unsupervised hierarchical
clustering of immune gene signature
scores in panel c
the frequency of tp53 mutated cases was
87 75 and
8 only respectively in patients with
high
intermediate and low immune filtration
and in line with our in silico analysis
of
tcga data immune checkpoints pdl1 and
lux3
fox p3 interfering gamma cd8 and grand
time b
a molecule recently associated with
features of
exhaustion and senescence in aml
were more highly expressed in patients
with pp53 mutated aml
compared with tp53 wild type aml
so we next analyze the immune
trasketonic profile
at the gene level and we identify the
set of
34 differentially expressed immune genes
between patients with
p53 mutated and p53 y-type aml
as shown in panels a and b and we will
refer to this
set of differentially expressed genes as
tp53 neon gene classifier
the p53 indian signature genes have not
been previously
implicated in the tp-63 pathway
as shown in venn diagram by the lack of
any overlap with hallmark
db53 gene sets downloaded from the
molecular signature database
so the differential expressed molecules
exhibited enrichment of keg pathways
related to
cytokine cytokine receptor interactions
autoimmune
inflammatory processes and i7 mediated
and tnf
mediated signaling as shown in panels a
and b we then assess the
differentially expressed genes in silico
again for
potential prognostic value in tcga aml
cases
and abnormalities of the 19 immune genes
that were overexpressed
in patients with tb53 mutated aml
and by default this means rna of
regulation
gene amplification deep deletion and
missend mutations
significantly correlated with worse
relapse free survival
and overall survival estimates as shown
by the kepler-major curves
in panel c by contrast the 15 immune
genes that were done regulated in
patients with
tp53 mutated aml carried no prognostic
significance and this data
are not shown here
so next we wanted to determine whether
tp53 abnormalities
identify a subgroup of patients with
relapsed
refractory aml that may benefit from
immunotherapy with flutter suture map
cd123
by cd3 by specific dart molecule for
redirecting
host t cells to aml in the cp mgd
0601 clinical trial so flutitis drop is
an investigational
by specific antibody based molecule to
cd3 epsilon and cd123
engineered in a dart format phlogetism
binds both tumor and effector cells to
promote
the formation of immunological synapse
and to redirect
polyclonal effector t cells to kill ams
blasts
in a major histocompatibility complex
independent manner
so this slide summarizes the clinical
characteristics of the fortifies
patients in the flooded tuzumab cohort
median age at time of study entry was 61
years
approximately 75 percent of the patients
had an
unfavorable cytogenetic risk based on
the
2017 eln classification
15 patients in this cohort had either
pp53 mutations or deletions of 17p
to which p53 is mapped that are usually
associated with loss of one
allele of tp53 and mutation loss of the
other
and response in this study was assessed
by
modified iwg criteria and specifically
complete response
less than five percent bone marrow
blasts were defined as either
complete remission complete remission
with partial hematopoietic recovery
complete remission with incomplete
hematopoietic recovery or
morphologic leukemia-free state mlfs
no response was defined as either
treatment failure
stable disease or progressive disease
so baseline bone marrow samples for
immune gene expression profiling
were available in 13 out of 15 patients
with
tp53 mutations and or genomic loss of
tb-53
among these 10 patients showed
intermediate to high
immune infiltration as highlighted by
the heat map in panel a
on treatment and time to patient death
and or censoring
are summarized in panel b for patients
with
tp53 mutations and or 17p
abnormalities including three patients
who proceeded to receive allergenic
hematopoietic stem cell transplantation
so the overall response rate was 60
percent
nine out of 15 patients with 47 percent
of
them achieving complete response as
defined by
less than five percent bone marrow
blasts on study
and in responders with p53 mutations
median overall survival was 10.3 months
with a range from 3.3 to 21.3 months
suggesting that fluctuation may
alleviate
the negative prognostic impact of tp53
abnormalities in aml
so the reduction of bone marrow blasts
in
14 patients with tp53 abnormalities for
whom
a post cycle one bone marrow sample was
available
averaged 51.2 percent as shown in panel
a in patients
with mutations of tp53 and with evidence
of response
the tumor inflammation signature
interferon gamma
t reg cd8 and exhaustion gene expression
scores
were significantly higher at baseline
compared with non-responders
as shown in panel b highlighting the
association between response to t-cell
engagers such as flotituzumab
and the t-cell inflamed tumor
microenvironment
we also identified a set of genes that
were differentially expressed
between patients with tp53 abnormalities
and those with p53 wild type aml
and that were associated with response
to flooded system up
interestingly cd8b was the top ranking
gene
associated with response with an artwork
value
of 0.879 as shown in panel b
and finally flow cytometry experiments
performed by
mike reddick at university of washington
using bone marrow samples from
patients on study showed a trend towards
higher percentages
of cda t cells in individuals with
mutations of tp53
therefore validating the transatomic
findings of this study
so just to conclude my talk immune
transphotomic analysis of in silico
and white lab cohorts of tp53 mutated
aml
suggests the presence of high t cell
infiltration and high expression of
immune checkpoints
and interferon gamma signaling molecules
compare with aml subgroups with
other risk defining molecular lesions
experimentally derived tp53 related
immune gene signatures
are significant for survival prediction
in aml
our translational study has shown that
immunotherapy with flotissus map
has efficacy in individuals with altered
tp53 status
with an overall reduction of bone marrow
blasts averaging
15.2 percent and overall sorry 51.2
percent at an overall response rate of
60
we believe that these findings encourage
further studies of flotivisumab in
larger cohorts of patients who harbor
this molecular lesion so this is my
acknowledgement slide i wish to express
my thanks to co-authors
collaborators from many different many
institutions around the world and also
funding
sources i will be very happy to take
questions if you
do not mind emailing me thank you very
much for listening
that was fantastic um actually i have
some uh questions as well for you dr
vitola if you can um
answer perfect so what is the
recommended input of rna for the
analysis of bone marrow samples
yeah so we generally use approximately
nanograms per ml from unmanipulated bone
marrow samples
and our samples were always looking very
very good in terms of
qc so we almost never had any any qc
issue with this amount of rna
perfect and did you use purified
leukemia blasts in your experiments
no we didn't so we used unmanipulated
bone marrow samples because the
aim of this investigation was to gain
insight into the
composition of the tumor map environment
so we didn't want to work with purified
aml blast to do this
great um is there any evidence from
solid tumors that tp53 mutations
associate with response to immunotherapy
actually there is evidence in lung
cancer that patients with mutations of
tp53 may respond to
immune checkpoints blockade yes
so dr rotella this is um pretty exciting
times with the whole spatial
you know revolution you can do both gene
expression analysis adding on spatial
findings
i'm curious to hear your thoughts on
these techniques and you know how
they're related and integrated and how
you would apply
these types of technologies moving
forward
yeah so this is a great question and
it's a very interesting point
so we are trying to integrate molecular
lesions which are established
prognosticators in the clinic
with the immune subtype we have
generated a considerable amount of
information suggesting that
immune subtypes may predict resistance
to chemotherapy and also response to
immunotherapy
so i think it would be very important to
validate these findings uh prospectively
and of course using the nanostring
approach has
several potential advantages including
the rapid
turnover for this to 48 hours and also
the ability to
customize your own panels you may want
to include as i just mentioned
uh established molecular prognostic
lesions as well as
genes that capture the functional
orientation of the immunological tumor
micro environment so
i really look forward to the
translational
elements of this research
fantastic and then finally are there
other genetic drivers of cancer
associated with a hot tumor
microenvironment
so yes in our study we have identified
rank 1
mutations as being associated with a hot
tumor micro environment and
again ranks 1 mutations correlate with
poor clinical outcomes in email
and there is evidence published by
others in solid tumors and specifically
in lung cancer
that k-ras and n-grass mutations may be
associated with a hot
tumor mark environment
great thank you so much i really enjoyed
your talk and really appreciate you
sharing your research with us this is
fantastic
thank you very much